you j'espère que vous allez bien petit
décor un petit peu différent parce que
j'ai pas pu tourner dans mon endroit
habituel mais c'est pas de ça dont je
vous parlais voudrais vous parler d'un
sondage qui est sorti à quelques
semaines qui a fait pas mal de bruit
sortie le 15 septembre et ça s'appelle
fractures françaises 2020 ça a été fait
par l'ipsos pour le monde est dedans il
ya une question qui est êtes vous
d'accord avec le fait qu'il faudrait
rétablir la peine de mort en france
et ça fait beaucoup de bruit parce que
depuis que ce sondage existe la réponse
oui elle n'a jamais été aussi élevé
parce que là elle a atteint 55%
pourquoi c'est aussi élevé est ce que
c'est grave qu'est ce que ça implique
c'est les questions auxquelles on va
essayer de répondre dans cette vidéo
par ailleurs cette vidéo est faite en
collaboration avec amnesty international
qui m'avait contacté à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale contre la peine de mort
donc bien avant ce sondage et je précise
que j'ai changé en rien mes opinions
pour cette vidéo et qu'il y ait amnesty
international ou non ça change rien à ce
que je dis mais par contre ça fait que
les chiffres que je vous sors et les
données sont vérifiées et ça c'est
rassurant quand même alors 55% des
français qui sont pour la peine de mort
ça paraît beaucoup et comme on a dit
c'est le plus haut chiffre depuis que ce
sondage existe c'est à dire depuis six
ans mais en fait par rapport à la
moyenne du sondage c'est pas un si gros
bon que ça puisque la moyenne elle est
de 49%
c'est difficile de savoir pourquoi on a
une telle augmentation mais globalement
ça vient toujours d'un sentiment
d'insécurité par exemple l'autre année
la plus élevée c'est l'année des
attentats de charlie hebdo vous en
parler sur instagram
il y en a certains et certaines d'entre
vous qui me disait que c'est aussi
peut-être parce qu'on met plus la
lumière sur la pédocriminalité les viols
et les féminicides c'est aussi une piste
on peut aussi imaginer que ça rejoint
une logique anti système sert qui veut
aller à l'encontre de l'idéologie
dominante
c'est quelque chose qu'on a beaucoup
observé ces dernières semaines où ces
derniers mois on peut même imaginer que
ça a un lien avec le fait qu'on observe
d'après l'organisme respecte zone une
augmentation de 60 % par an du nombre de
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
appelant à la violence
ou bien c'est peut être aussi simplement
l'envié où le besoin d'avoir une
autorité un état fort
quelque chose de rassurant quoi sauf que
rien de tout ça peut être résolu par la
peine de mort je vous expliquer pourquoi
mais avant je vous parlais de moi quand
j'étais jeune j'étais pour la peine de
mort voilà c'est un peu gênant d'en
parler et j'espère ne pas trop me faire
juger pour cette opinion mais c'est une
réalité
je me disais utilitariste l'idée c'était
de maximiser le bien être collectif
et pour moi ça et contribuer puisque
voilà ont tué une personne et en échange
toute la société était sereine et on
arrive ma préférée c'était l'argument
financier sert que voilà nourrir et
loger quelqu'un toute sa vie non merci
quoi au démarrage c'est quelqu'un de
sympathique 1 j'étais juste j'imagine un
petit peu cynique vis-à-vis de la vie
voilà et puis après j'ai découvert le
jazz et je me sers que quand je disais
que j'étais pour la peine de mort ça
gênait certaines personnes mais c'est
relativement accepter quoi c'est comme
si j'imagine aujourd'hui on explique on
est pour le port d'armes
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec cette
opinion on peut ne pas la comprendre
on peut ne pas vouloir la soutenir mais
on va pas forcément coupé court une
discussion à cause de ça du moins à
l'époque c'était comme ça et je pense
que le fait que je pouvais dire
ouvertement que j'étais pour la peine de
mort c'était il ya deux choses d'abord
le fait qu'elle soit pas mal pratiqué
dans le monde et aussi que en france son
abolition est quand même hyper récente
si on se remet dans le contexte en mai
1977 star wars sort en france au cinéma
sauf que la peine de mort n'est pas
encore aboli la dernière exécution
ça sera en septembre 1977 à marseille et
je trouve ça ou en fait tout ça où je
désire que star wars est sorti alors
qu'on n'en a pas fini avec la guillotine
alors que la guillotine ça a vraiment
une image hyper vieille dans notre
esprit en fait pas tant que ça ses
contemporains de star wars et d'ailleurs
c'est tellement récent que dans un
quartier que j'aime bien dans paris on
voit encore des traces de la guillotine
sur le sol c'est rue de la croix fauvin
et voyez sur le solde il ya cinq dalle
ça l'a aussi et ça servait à dresser
l'échafaud de la guillotine serment que
c'est pas si vieux que ça et ça peut se
comprendre
parce que quand on y réfléchit à la
va-vite l'abolition de la peine de mort
c'est pas si évident et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs pour ça que les français sont
restés favorables à la peine de mort
jusqu en 99 et c'est aussi ça qui donne
le sondage dont je vous ai parlé au
début de la vidéo par exemple
je pense que l'une des raisons qui fait
que le débat elle est toujours là ce que
justement parfois c'est quelque chose
qu'on prend trop pour acquis ce qui
s'explique aussi parce que c'est inscrit
dans la constitution suis d'accord mais
je lisais une super interview de laura
my gavériaux chercheuse en philosophie à
la sorbonne elle répondait à la question
qu'est ce que les profs enseigne sur la
peine de mort et j'ai adoré sa réponse
je vous la lire grosso modo on apprend
aux élèves que c'est mal mais c'est pas
forcément contrebalancer on érige le
modèle français en idéal on fait un peu
réfléchir sur la notion de vengeance
mais c'est tout c'est pour ça qu'on en
arrive là il n'y a pas de réelle
réflexion sur la raison pour laquelle on
a aboli la peine de mort et décider
d'instruire et de punir dans un cadre
normatif relativement libéral on laborde
de façon trop simpliste en fait et elle
continue après je ne suis pas fan de la
notion de débats libres car ça laisse
entendre aux élèves qu'on peut exprimer
n'importe quoi c'est pour ça que le
corps enseignant buts sur les questions
autour de dieudonné
charlie etc il ne s'agit pas de brider
l'expression des élèves mais d'assumer
qu'il ya des choix de société et qui
sont parfois contestables ailleurs notre
société a fait des choix culturels et on
laissera forcément deux côtés des gens
qui ne seront pas d'accord
mais même si c'est discutable c'est
comme ça aujourd'hui on cherche le
consensus partout mais on oublie qu'on
va glisser sur des croyances religieuses
éthique personnelle fondamentale or
c'est pour cela qu'il ya un processus de
décision politique
ouais je la trouve très très forte
j'aime beaucoup ce qui est dit sur le
côté acquis de l'abolition de la peine
de mort est effectivement sa partie du
souci que ceux qui sont pour la peine de
mort et ceux qui sont contre la peine de
mort en fait non pas vraiment l'occasion
de débattre ni de s'écouter et du coup
je me dis que ça pouvait être
intéressant que je vous donne mon
processus de pensée et comment je suis
passé de d'être pour la peine de mort à
contre je me dis que ça peut peut-être
vous faire réfléchir sur la question
alors qu'est ce qui m'a fait changer
d'avis sur la peine de mort c'est un peu
privé mais c'est le jour où mon grand
frère a été jugé pour homicide
involontaire
c'est faux il faut évidemment je le
salue d'ailleurs
c'est faux j'ai pas grand frère en frère
non en vrai c'est dur de retracer sa un
événement précis c'est pas vraiment
précis c'est quelque chose qui est très
progressif c'est un chemin intellectuel
très solitaire aussi et c'est pas tant
une histoire d'argumentaire et c'est
plus un changement de conception sur ce
qu'est la justice
est ce qu'on peut se permettre de faire
en tant que société en fait c'est tout
un tas de réflexion externe je pense
qu'ils ont nourri cette réflexion là en
fait la question je veux se poser c'est
à quel moment ces logiques de tuer
quelqu'un pour avoir tué ou fait du mal
à quelqu'un en fait ça ressemble plus à
la vengeance qu'elle la justice et en
toute logique on peut pas demander en
tant que société a des gens d'arrêter de
tuer d'autres gens si nous mêmes en tant
que société on continue de le faire
aussi ouvertement et directement en fait
ça a titillé vraiment mon esprit hyper
logique et quelque part très cartésien
cynique tout ce que vous voulez mais en
fait non je sais ça ne marche pas quoi
mathématiquement c'est possible je t'ai
pas un gars très sentimental j'étais pas
un gars très sentimental
ça a changé un petit peu depuis mai moi
c'était vraiment la logique du truc je
ne comprends pas ça n'a pas de sens en
france effectivement on s'est basé sur
l'état de droit et sur les droits de
l'homme et de la femme dans ce type de
société les codes pénaux il prévoit pas
d'incendié les maisons des incendiaires
de violer les violeurs de torsionnelle
et tortionnaires en fait on est parti du
principe qu'on va se fonder sur d'autres
valeurs que les valeurs des individus
qu'on condamne et pour moi ça c'est
vraiment un élément fondamental contre
la peine de mort qui vais je me suis
intéressé à d'autres éléments et
d'autres arguments alors une des raisons
avancées
c'est que c'est dissuasif et ça j'avoue
même quand j'étais pour la peine de mort
j'avais du mal avec cet argument quoi
maintenant c'est pas du tout dissuasif
en fait de se faire tuer par l'état rien
que le concept par exemple d'attentats
suicide montre que les gens qui veulent
tuer d'autres gens s'en foutent
en fait de mourir la plupart du temps
faim la mort n'est pas toujours
dissuasive
en fait lorsque effectivement si c'était
vrai dans les pays où il ya une
abolition de la peine de mort on verrait
la criminalité qui monte en flèche
et c'est pas le cas en fait par exemple
si on regarde juste le canada entre 1976
et 2008 la communauté elle a été réduite
de moitié en france ça s'est réduit
aussi mais pas autant mais en tous les
cas y'a pas un envol de la criminalité
parce qu'il ya plus la peine de mort
quoi donc la peine de mort
là dessus m
à jamais les problèmes de criminalité
est donc d'insécurité c'est pas du tout
lié en fait encore une fois parce que
les gens qui tuent ou qui font du mal
autour d'eux ils ont des motivations qui
sont plus forte que la peur de mourir
pour ce qui est mon argument préférées
l'argument financier les tunes bas âge
et après que même ça même ça dans
certains cas c'est totalement faux et
c'est même l'un versent parfois c'est à
dire que condamner quelqu'un à mort
coûte plus cher parfois que le ou la
garder en prison toute sa vie et non
plus au début j'ai pas compris je vous
expliquais par exemple aux états unis
les procès qu'implique une peine de mort
ils sont beaucoup plus lourds ils
demandent plus d'avocats plus d'experts
plus de recours et c'est ce qui fait que
par exemple en 2009 l'état du nouveau
mexique qui était en pleine crise
économique
eh ben ils ont aboli la peine de mort
parce que ça leur faisait perdre trop
d'argent
donc même cet argument qui paraît
évident à certaines fois il n'est pas du
tout et je vous parle même pas des
erreurs judiciaires gens par exemple
l'année dernière il y avait deux détenus
aux états unis qui était dans le couloir
de la mort ils ont été innocentés
après avoir passé 40 ans en prison je
pense qu'on vaut mieux que ça je pars
pas non plus du caractère
intrinsèquement inégalitaire de la peine
de mort puisque les inégalités sociales
et économiques empêchent un certain
accès à la justice donc si une personne
est accusée et qu'elle est pauvre elle à
pouvoir plus difficilement se défend
clairement s'ils ont rétabli la peine de
mort c'est pas pour les riches
contrairement à tout ce que je vous dis
là tout ce que je vous dis depuis
plusieurs minutes j'ai du mal à trouver
une bonne raison pour défendre la peine
de mort quand on change d'avis sur un
truc qui est aussi important et clivant
m'a déjà on est bien content qu'il ait
pas de trace sur le net quand j'étais
jeune j'étais pour la peine de mort et
hop c est aussi on se rend compte de à
quel point on se définit pas par ses
opinions j'ai pas radicalement changé
entre le moment où j'étais pour et le
monde était contre et je trouve que on a
tendance à un petit peu trop
s'identifier à ses opinions et ça on en
reparlera je pense dans une autre vidéo
sa mairie d'une vidéo entier relations
aujourd'hui globalement le monde se
dirige vers une absence de peine de mort
en 99 il y avait trente et un pays qui
avait exécuté un condamné à mort en 2018
il y en avait que 20 voilà donc c'est
une réduction de plus d'un tiers mais
c'est pas héros est aujourd'hui les deux
plus gros leaders du monde bat son
propre haine de maurs et les états unis
et la chine
aux etats unis c'est quelque chose qui
fait beaucoup débat en chine c'est très
opaque
c'est pas assumer on n'a même pas les
chiffres du nombre d'exécutions chaque
année
et j'en profite d'ailleurs pour préciser
quelque chose que j'avais pas du tout
dans les pays qui la pratiquent encore
c'est pas du tout que l'homicide en fait
qu'on condamne ça peut être aussi
quelque chose en rapport avec la
sexualité le placent fait mme la drogue
l'adultère voilà des choses qui sont pas
au niveau de l'homicide donc aujourd'hui
comme on peut le voir sur cette carte il
ya assez peu de pays qui continuent de
la pratique est activement et d'ailleurs
bonne nouvelle l'année dernière c'était
l'année avec le moins d'exécutions
recensé de la décennie mais quand on
voit que même en france ça peut revenir
dans le débat
on se dit que c'est peut-être à qui
juridiquement mais moralement ou
philosophiquement le travail n'est pas
fini et c'est pour ça qu'une journée
comme la journée mondiale contre la
peine de mort c'est aussi là pour nous
le rappeler
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
joué plus de ressources d'amnesty
international en descriptions ils ont
notamment une chaîne youtube avec des
enquêtes des documentaires qui défonce
donc n'hésitez pas à voir ça c'est assez
marrant qu'il ya eu ce sondage qui
qu'ils soient arrivés il ya quelques
semaines où je me suis dis parce que je
travaille déjà sur cette vidéo et je me
dis que c'était vraiment l'occasion
parfaite et ça a tellement entraîné de
bruit de débat et c'est que je me suis
dit voilà c'est le genre de sujet qui
est quand même assez important
et comme moi même je vous dis j'ai fait
ce ce changement d'opinion
je trouve ça cool de vous en parler et
j'espère que voilà ça va inspirer
certains d'entre vous avoue peut-être
reposer la question sur surtout sa love
peace chao et au passage je crois pas
que les 55 % de français soit vraiment
pour le retour de la peine de mort crois
que c'était plus une manière de pousser
un coup de gueule mais je suis peut-être
naïf